le 7 octobre avant même les premiers
résultats des partisans de gerbe also
know crié à la fraude et brûler des
reproductions de boîtes de scrutin
électronique leur candidat ne pouvait
pas ne pas gagner dès le premier tour et
il en avait vu la preuve dans les médias
sociaux dans la messagerie whatsapp en
particulier que tous les brésiliens
utilisent cela ne doit pas se reproduire
exige le tribunal suprême électoral qui
a ordonné à facebook et google de
retirer 55 liens vers les dénonciations
de cette fraude par jaillir ball sonar
ou lui-même sa présidente rosa webber a
dénoncé ces faits news a fait guiniot
formation elles minent la crédibilité de
la justice électorale dit elle et elle
mérite une réponse appropriée
ascanio selena est un des principaux
chroniqueurs du grand quotidien o globo
à cause des médias sociaux de whatsapp
la campagne est totalement hors contrôle
dit il michi de formation et mensonges
diffamation calomnie quand des mensonges
répétés par des millions de personnes
ça devient une verrine tu as reçu ce
coup dur il y aura des sanctions
mais quand c'est le problème pas dit
s'il second tour c'est une première dit
l'organisation des états américains elle
n'avait monclin siens c'est la première
fois dans une démocratie qu'on utilise
whatsapp pour diffuser massivement des
fausses nouvelles noticias communication
est menacée l'ancienne présidente du
costa rica rencontre est le candidat du
parti des travailleurs fernando haddad
soyez vigilants dimanche dit il enfin
son contrat qui prend domingo on doit
éviter comme au premier tour cette
avalanche de fausses nouvelles
son adversaire a dit de son côté que
jamais la population n'accepterait une
victoire de la gauche et dimanche car il
y aurait eu fraude
nul doute été aussi mis en garde contre
les fausses nouvelles de la gauche
jacques bolson arrow qui ne fait
pratiquement pas campagne continue de
baisser dans les sondages alors que son
adversaire fernand
haddad très active très visible lui
remonte tranquillement la pente mais il
n'est pas au bout de ses peines
douze points d'écart à deux jours du
scrutin c'est pratiquement impossible à
rattraper
jean michel leprince traits du canada
rio de janeiro